[Laughter]
[Music]
not even that's not even not a thing I'm
ready to get back in working I can't get
in
[ __ ] I came against too late watching
that's so weird the window whenever
someone talks you know like have static
that's weird
okay well what's going on are you
getting me in invite me in
in Miami dude hey Craig are we gonna use
this art this audio or whatever for the
podcast
since you're not going to stream because
he's not even just go to coke I'm
leaving idiot
no I was in the team I don't know I
wouldn't let you join maybe cuz you both
try it at the same time I don't know
it's not even use Griffin stream that's
not even working what's not working okay
it's like that's not joining I can't
join anybody's thing hey coke invite
that please we gonna check our - as
excited about this new Lisa Lampanelli
special like nobody care we retain abou
so start with no no
WUF I won't do it through you texture on
the behalf of Craig I mean this is just
[Laughter]
dude I'm sliding out of the ends oh my
here we go
[Music]
no dude I'm gonna ask her I'll be like
the corporate law corporate Craig wanted
to know if you wanted to be a guess for
what Craig I got no dude that's even
color Peaks this is what pieces he like
right now there you go partner
you guys do it trials r.i.p oh my god
I'm just horrible at this game guys guys
stick together
alright let's not [ __ ] with them let
them play for real I want him to go the
tower oh yeah yeah we played last game
you know communicating each other follow
each other I just I just died from the
sky burners off oh why the river I don't
understand like my gun just doesn't work
up you gotta hit their head coach I'm
not gonna lie to you we gotta get ones
that guy we were playing with yesterday
yeah
over your name all right I'm watching
you guys so don't let he got me
yeah oh [ __ ] did he pick up our yeah
[Music]
over there oh my god okay Griffin
there's gonna be a guy in that corner
there's a guy on Griffin
[ __ ] yeah if I get a forget effusion
this [ __ ] is too dramatic
I'm gonna go up River yeah River don't
don't go out over there by see not one
coming up on us one of them went in this
there over here in this game my guard is
good now the darkest before is really
good there's two up on top here take our
share with the need he's on top of me oh
oh [ __ ] I'm shooting another I'm
shooting each other getting hit from the
[ __ ] side
Heather's comedy got me I just [ __ ]
shoot a sure dude she's we got that stop
get the slam slam guys down wasted that
[ __ ] there's send me a link I don't know
I'm with you oh god we did that make
sure that Griffin gets she like she
liked one of our posts Craig and you
liked one of her photos
oh that's major stalking right there is
that is that like this van storied you
going through all the kids eggplants or
pictures I don't know how it's another
young
I see also calls me you stop saying I
write there she oh my god - laughs if
your left I got the room there's a guy
though you how you left it was still
another guy to the left guys trying
oh my god I made a bunch of woods
there's one coming he's heard over there
damn Eric just wipe that [ __ ] up he's in
that corner oh that's a terrible racket
that was a waste of super man not being
able to run is just the worst yeah you
know I know
Thank You captain obvious it's been a
while well it has its days dude it's
[ __ ] weird
let me tell them banana boy and you can
tell us friends and then at the
Microsoft Store in LA to help you nice I
got my area narrow that on me that been
the river done there
that guy had sky bitters Oh watch out
Oh Steve to the left of your teeth oh I
wasted they ran away
how did that guy thank you got me Oh
last hope I had no idea where he was
behind the circle yep behind us
I got some marks all over your
ingredient that swag guys got a fusion
rifle guys watch out he's coming good
traded one guy world Pilates anyways -
God 10 kill streak Jesus oh my god yeah
it was that right you think we could win
three we come on three right no you guys
are gonna win it all the way I believe
all the way yeah it's possible we've
done it before you have yeah let's just
go mitre say [ __ ] and go mida you
know I mean little [ __ ] [ __ ] I go
Maya Bazar when you coming down here I
got I got a flashlight for you man have
to say that when you're giving somebody
something like that oh and it's still in
the box
Arthur told them about it yeah I was
[Music]
hard to hide that [ __ ] doesn't look like
a flashlight
stick together
he's hurt whoa oh my god we got one in
there
Christ I just come out of nowhere these
guys are sticking together like glue
he got a sore work day I see him we're
gonna call out for heroin and coke I got
to trade in your morning store guys in
the middle ID statue
everybody go to code oh they turned a
corner was three of them how did he get
it oh he you know bad start era I'm
following Errol are you going up top
here oh yeah
at the other end hey kill them finally
someone let the music but griffin what's
your second is that oh my god I don't
know how to end up on me every single
time I'm chasing them god damn it the
five-string I knew what the sword era oh
I almost kept it out of there yep and
then there's a why he just comes after
to serve me I guess oh my god I'm trying
I got his ass [ __ ] I'm out coming up on
TV the enemy has the edge ain't Griffin
eat your tires machine don't for your
secondary but Uriel is not his found
here
I'm tethered up here and the only ones
over don't come to where I am I'm
getting pinched both angles why didn't
that kill him for arc soul and at melee
attack it's not gonna kill someone I
mean this is [ __ ] ridiculous
yes power he's going through crying
stole that kill that warning was a
little late you guys can beat them enemy
intends to finish is to come back we'll
see you building cook super close super
close
oh you got me
he wished isn't over [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] on me and trine and he gave tip
no I love that dude and love that it
makes so much sense your kid Griffin
keep running the arc staffs through oh
are you coming from a mile away
yeah oh [ __ ]
so headed again I'm getting hit from two
sides
on your left very different
[ __ ] why am i jumping around
Oh jump is sucked I'm floating it I have
to heavy
let's go again let's go you probably did
it unless you guys got three losses
it'll reset on its own I'm gonna back
out so Griffin can switch his guns
haven't shut the [ __ ] up highlight over
Travis yeah let me know what you're
ready girl okay I'll hold down X okay
got you yeah ready have two pulses yeah
the Pikachu how do you hit on on the
ladies from junior high you send them
like postcards you know he loved him the
best healer from what do i do Pikachu
what do I do I send their dick pic we
already discussed this that your dick
pic should never go anywhere okay if
there were ever dick pics on my iPhone
would probably break on its own let's
talk about Craig's dick wage discussion
Craig's dick I was away from my mic
there for a second I just started coming
back and here
following Craig follows gaze of girls
club Oh what's going on what are you
talking about they're big group they
follow us dude
I follow back everybody that follows us
- he's still high in there
then the elbow over there yes I'm the
busy guy behind me back in that elbow
turn around everybody listen the arrow
behind on TV on TV these are here coke
yeah I got him behind the honey
I'll get his health back
but there's another guy in a I got him
Steve oh my god is one [ __ ] guy and
he gets me Jesus Christ
hey Christ nice suit yeah let him
concentrate I win the concentrate the
only way to go it's I think it's like
two shots and they're dead you can get
them with just three body shots
they're all on see two of them at least
one of them going around to the shrine
inside oh my god
and then but then like I didn't have it
loaded which I don't understand that
Oh prosecutor still weak you got power
Oh Steve stole my kill I'm not I'm up
hey Craig what do you think I think
these guys can still win it you're just
gonna work together getting chased and
trying he's gonna go straight to your
left
[ __ ] my corpse all these
[ __ ] you [ __ ] over
here in the cave
we're oh my god oh my god like actually
takes a power away from you I think cuz
this [ __ ] is sucking a bag of dicks all
the things do they get power I think
they did I'm getting shut out in front
only all together outside cuz this guide
you there's no running away I mean
there's just no running away some I
start shooting you you're dead no I
can't run dude me not being able to run
it's just not helping either
[Laughter]
you're gonna have oh my god no we want
we won they're on be
there's one up here some of this arc
sole up from the side
I made some orbs up knocks down
Oh behind me oh my god behind you
I know it's unbelievable they got power
on me they're all in the middle by
people they madman Griffin check out
what powers up go for Steve oh my god oh
my me just keep playing us guys
I should get my Golden Gun this round
what are they trying I can't get here
some they're here just corner the elbow
oh my god they're in that little yeah
whatever this is called
you have a frog I gotta hurt one with my
grenade on heavy
pull it up make it sound right brother
there's some power she's right it's
innate yeah they got Rockets a for sure
got Rockets there's a guy behind me oh
my god I'm out so good yeah are we lost
hi Craig Pikachu get in there Pikachu
so much for man come and cook this
joystick as any girls actually like dick
pics has anybody ever been excited by
dick pics I just I'm just curious
I've never heard a girl be like I got an
amazing dick pic the other day I love I
love when you berate your brother who
sounds like he's 20 years older than you
compared to yours it's like octaves well
yeah sound is lower
Oh Steve's the leader
you got to mm-hmm I became that step
yeah yeah yeah
sorry just give me one second just
rearranging there we go Alan be quiet
please
it does not cause a sense 15:15 and
you're getting on him like that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
between teddy bears there enshrine
oh and there's BK oh my god
all right I'm coming I'm coming
oh my god I just can't stand when
nobody's around I just don't get at
least we know what when their one rocket
is shot that's it all right I got one
there in the there in the cave where the
heavy is yeah yeah all right all right
behind you Koch let's get this let's go
oh my god did okay now not only watch to
your left there there you go
damnit
we can beat these guys they're not that
good I've never do it but we're not
going to tell me from your behind coke
oh my god [ __ ] tear man Jesus coke
nah he's fine
we can beat these guys these guys are
beatable you think so
yeah yeah for sure we just got to
communicate to each other and tries to
steer next to coke all right just follow
coke coke where you going man you going
through the river yeah yeah I'll pass
alright I'm gonna I'm gonna stay here
and hold heavy
I'm gonna watch heavy you guys watch her
flanks cuz they're gonna come from
around right there in front of us there
you go up top be
I cease lagging to assert oh my god this
[ __ ] what happened oh [ __ ] once
I get shots too late boom oh my [ __ ]
dude
yes I'm lagging to boot
one of the hunters I think yeah it is
the hunter yeah so bad dude
he was like jumping around I couldn't
hit him oh my god oh yeah this guy's
crap crap Edie whatever yes bad it's
like really bad yeah he lagged he just
killed me crap the dog rap the dog dad
alright I'm out try and stay next to
coke guys heavies up there has no mercy
here I just got colony
10 seconds look at him
that guy's lagging so hard soon right I
know it's [ __ ] up man it's already
hard enough to to shoot the gun you're
God's one what one is it what what
what's his name
crap his name's crop the dog he's yeah
yeah the dog yeah yeah he is crappy it's
a connection is dog [ __ ] they're leaving
from there into the heavy tunnels yeah I
got one one that me from the side
what the for my god so annoying you know
no radar why didn't it I'm just so over
this yeah I crap the dog I couldn't even
hit him everybody has their super oh
great you want to stop in man we're not
doing too good no come on dude what do
you mean these guys are like switch and
either cheating days everybody take a
drink watch out behind you Steve Steve
behind you hello no arcs damn pipe heavy
almost got him oh my god is the lighter
oh yeah crap the dog
taking a message about we should
challenging to UFC dude it's not UFC MMA
Wow
[ __ ] these dudes oh that was a good one
good tether yeah I had to do it
talking smells it was perfect Oh watch
out art staff where they get where they
are you [ __ ] oh my god this guy just
disappeared they're all I guess guys
like I was watching it I was watching
you skipping around the map yeah
okay I'm gonna report that that's cheap
oh my god
he waves [ __ ] cheaters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]